[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
das wird ein langer wahlabend das ist
sicher aber das ist eben auch sicher
dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger ihr
kreuz bei der spd gemacht haben weil sie
wollen dass es einen wechsel in der
regierung gibt und auch weil sie wollen
dass der nächste kanzler des landes und
auf scholz heißt
eine stimme für die union ist eine
stimme gegen eine links geführte
bundesregierung
deshalb werden wir alles daran setzen
eine bundesregierung unter führung der
union zu bilden der in deutschland
so können zwei fast das gleiche sagen
und dabei voll auf kollisionskurs liegen
guten abend der ist noch nicht vorbei
und auch wenn er dann mal vorbei ist
werden wir nicht wissen wie merkels
nachfolger am ende heißt laschet oder
scholz eines scheint klar ist wird wohl
der von den beiden sein der ist in den
nächsten wochen schafft grünen und der
fdp das attraktivere angebot zu machen
das ist das bundestagswahlergebnis
oberflächlich in zehn sekunden matthias
fornoff hat die details und zeigt damit
auch die grundlage für die komplizierten
verhandlungen die jetzt beginnen müssen
ja klar es gibt eine neue hochrechnung
man muss dazu sagen dass fließen immer
noch mehr daten rein ist fehlen
vereinigen auch viele briefwahl
ergebnisse es wird also was das betrifft
noch ein langer abend aber wir schauen
mal auf die aktuellste hochrechnung da
sehen wir die union bei 24,5 prozent
minus 8,4 punkte die spd bei 26 prozent
wäre dann stärkste partei und gewinnt
5,5 dazu afd 10,5 mit verlusten fdp 11,7
prozent mit gewinnen die linke 5 prozent
minus 4,2 und da muss man klar sagen das
ist absolut auf der kippe das kann auch
unter fünf prozent rutschen und ob es
dann reicht mit drei direktmandaten ob
sie die kriegt auch das ist ungewiss die
grünen bei 13,9 prozent und 5 punkten zu
gewinnen die anderen 8,4 die kleineren
parteien auch mit zu gewinnen was heißt
das für das regieren im bund
spd und cdu csu kämen auf 4 108 sitze im
neuen bundestag
371 braucht man das würde also deutlich
reichen für rot grün würde es auch
deutlich nicht reichen und für
schwarz-grün schon gar nicht das heißt
wenn nicht große koalition dann sind wir
bei dreier bündnissen da haben wir die
ampel spd grüne fdp die kommt deutlich
über diese grenze zur absoluten mehrheit
spd grüne und linke würde das nicht
schaffen selbst dann wenn die linke drin
wäre was wir gesagt zweifelhaft ist und
jamaika union grüne und fdp 4 105 sitze
auch das reicht also es gebe zurzeit
drei möglichkeiten eine regierung zu
bilden und
damit liegt wahrscheinlich die die
beiden parteien großen parteien haben ja
praktisch ausgeschlossen dass sie
nochmal eine neue groko machen damit
liegt die initiative bei der fdp und den
grünen richtig die sind im grunde das
zünglein an der waage und wir haben das
gehört in der berliner runde vorhin hat
der fdp-chef lindner genau das
vorgeschlagen dass grüne und fdp
zunächst einmal sondieren und man dann
sieht wo man seine ziele am besten
verwirklichen kann aber alle scheinen
finster entschlossen zu einem schnellen
ergebnis zu kommen anders als vor vier
jahren ich hoffe dass wir nachher noch
weitere analysen hinter diesen zahlen
schaffen matthias taste jetzt hat den
start der sendung die alten vorhersagen
also dass scholz keine chance hat
kanzler zu werden die hatten sich ja
schon vor vier wochen erledigt und die
überzeugung dass laschet heute abend
alle hoffnung fahren lassen muss sie hat
sich dann heute aufgelöst beide landeten
am ende auf gleicher augenhöhe
der eine kam von oben der andere von
unten winnie heescher über zwei halbe
wahlsieger heute abend
es wird offiziell auf scholz hat
krawatte an damit kommt er einen sieger
oder verlierer
wo seit gerhard schröder kein
spd-kanzlerkandidaten mehr grund zum
feiern hatte wohl nur elend und tränen
standen an wahlabenden wie diesen im
willy brandt haus wird nun olaf scholz
zusammen mit seiner frau vom applaus
getragen und scholz beansprucht die
kanzlerschaft für sich
das wird ein langer wahlabend das ist
sicher aber das ist eben auch sicher
dass viele bürgerinnen bürger ihr kreuz
bei der spd gemacht haben weil sie
wollen dass es einen wechsel in der
regierung gibt und auch weil sie wollen
dass der nächste kanzler des landes und
scholz
die spd hat einen weiten weg hinter sich
eingebürgert dass sie monatelang bei 14
15 prozent mit den fehlern der
konkurrenz legten sie zu jetzt steht
olaf scholz vorne aber hinter ihnen die
die in den sondierungsverhandlungen den
spielraum erhalten könnten saskia esken
und andere die linkere inhalte vertreten
als ihr kanzlerkandidat
fakt mathis muss zuversicht und
geschlossenheit das werden wir auch in
der nächsten zeit zeigen denn darauf
kommt es an und ich bin sicher die
bürgerinnen und bürger werden sich auch
nachträglich über ihre entscheidung
freuen die sie getroffen haben als sie
die spd gewählt haben dass das sprechen
gilt auch
armin laschet beendet seinen wahlkampf
wie ein streckenweise betrieben hat den
wahlschein falsch gefaltet seine
kreuzchen sichtbar ein weiterer fauxpas
verbreitet sich im netz doch der
verkorkste wahlkampf soll vergangenheit
sein armin laschet besucht seine letzte
chance mit dem historisch schlechtesten
ergebnis für die union indira geschichte
wagte er es noch an das kanzleramt zu
glauben alleine selbsternannte zukunft
koalition schmieden
der kampf ist vorbei jetzt geht es um 1
eine stabile koalition für ein starkes
und modernes deutschland und
bundeskanzler wird der dem es gelingt
gegensätze zu verbinden und ein gutes
gemeinsames programm für die nächsten
vier jahre zu entwickeln
dieses manöver dass laschet als nummer 2
platz eins beansprucht wollte die csu in
den vergangenen tagen nicht mittragen
heute abend tut sie es plötzlich doch
wir glauben fest an die idee eines
jamaika bündnis ist das wäre eine der
großen optionen dabei ist aber auch klar
dass das kein selbstläufer
alle müssen dann raus aus ihrer
komfortzone es kann keine lupenreine
parteipolitik gemacht werden sondern es
muss ein bündnis der vernunft sein in
diesen schweren zeiten
olaf scholz können sich noch ein bier
bevor in den wahlabend zur berliner
runde und allerlei interviews weiter
zieht er kennt die geschichtsbücher
schon vor ihm wurden männer nicht
kanzler obwohl sie im ergebnis vorne die
wahl ist zu ende der kampf noch lange
nicht
eines der allerlei interviews zu diesen
olaf scholz jetzt zieht ist bei uns und
jetzt live guten abend nach berlin da
schon
guten abend sie haben die stimme
mindestens auf dem ohr gehabt von herrn
söder und herrn laschet was die hier zu
sagen wenn sie das hören was geht ihnen
da durch den kopf
ich finde das wahlergebnis ist sehr
eindeutig die spd hat diese wahl
gewonnen und es ist auch so dass die
meisten bürgerinnen bürger sich wie auch
ihre umfragen bestätigen wünschen dass
sich der nächste regierungschef werde
wenn man schwanger
geworden sie nur sehr ungern aber wenn
sie sagen eindeutig gewonnen wir reden
da über möglicherweise bruchteile eines
prozent ist das wirklich ein mandat am
ende gewinnt der die wahl der die
koalition für eine kanzlermehrheit
zusammenbringt und es gibt keine
verpflichtungen der fdp und der grünen
für sie zu stimmen
nein die gibt es nicht das muss ja
miteinander besprochen werden nun auch
zustande gebracht werden wie man eine
regierungsmehrheit bildet aber das ist
glaube ich doch auch ganz klar die
bürgerinnen bürger haben wir entschieden
es gibt zustimmung die wächst bei der
spd in großem umfang zeigen dass ihre
berichte und die balken den nach oben
gehen das gleiche gibt es bei anderen
parteien bei der cdu da geht der balken
nach unten die bürgern bürger wollen
nicht dass die cdu die nächste regierung
führt und deshalb wird es meine aufgabe
und die von anderen seien eine
möglichkeit zu schaffen für eine
regierungsbildung die den wählerwillen
der hier sehr klar zum ausdruck gekommen
ist auch abbildet sie werden am ende die
fdp für sich gewinnen müssen mit
zugeständnissen sie haben es selbst in
ihrem haus mit einer neuen spd fraktion
zu tun die deutlich jünger ist die in
der tendenz linker ist als die fraktion
ist vorher war wie wollen sie denen
kompromisse mit der fdp verkaufen können
die spd ist eine lebendige volksparteien
das ist gut dass zum beispiel auch viele
jüngere abgeordnete jetzt in den
deutschen bundestag ziehen das wird uns
kraft geben und das ist für eine
volkspartei auch unabdingbar dass das
genau so passiert und klar ist die
politik die wir machen es die über die
ich jetzt auch vielen marktplätzen
gesprochen habe jeder verstanden hat aus
den vielen debatten an denen ich mich im
fernsehen und anderswo beteiligt habe es
wird eine pragmatische politik sein es
geht darum dass wir dafür sorge tragen
dass mir respekt in unserer gesellschaft
herrscht dass wir die industrielle
modernisierung hinbekommt und dass wir
den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufhalten alles das kann gelingen hier
müssen die weichen für die 20er jahre
richtig gestellt werden und wir wissen
genau wie das geht und darüber können
wir und wir haben wir uns auch mit
anderen verständigen sie haben
vielfältige investitionen versprochen
sie haben versprochen dass sie für ein
bezahlbares leben sorgen in allen
lebensaltern und haben große kosten
programme aufgestellt wie wollen sie die
finanziell vernünftig realisieren mit
einer partei wie jede steuererhöhungen
ablehnt und es ist wieder die fdp von
der ich spreche denn für sie werden die
gespräche mit der wahrscheinlich
schwieriger als mit den grünen
die industrielle modernisierung
deutschlands als das was wir machen
müssen nun den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
handelt im wesentlichen von
privatwirtschaftlichen investitionen das
ist nicht neu ich habe immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen wenn einige meint man
müsste die regeln des grundgesetzes auf
verändern die wir heute haben für ein
ordentliches wirtschaften dass das
meiste worum es jetzt geht
privatwirtschaftliche investitionen sind
also zum beispiel der ausbau der
windkraft auf hoher see der ausbau der
windkraft an land das stromnetz die
solarenergie das was wir brauchen wenn
der investitionen in der stahlindustrie
der chemieindustrie sehen beim zement
beim maschinenbau automobilbau das sind
privatwirtschaftliche investitionen und
für das was dann noch notwendiges sind
in der finanzplanung erhebliche
investitionsmittel vorgesehen und zwar
der finanzplanung die jetzt schon von
der bundesregierung auf den weg gebracht
worden ist die frage die ich jetzt noch
habe hat damit zu tun dass vor vier
jahren das absolut unmöglich scheinende
am ende doch möglich wurde können sie
wenn es zu schwierig wird mit fdp und
grünen und ihnen völlig für immer
ausschließen dass es doch noch einmal zu
einer großen koalition möglicherweise
dann unter ihrer führung kommt
dass es letztes mal zu dieser regierung
gekommen es hat etwas damit zu tun dass
die verhandlungen auch nicht besonders
gut gelaufen sind die vorher unternommen
worden waren zwischen cdu/csu fdp und
grüne und deshalb finde ich ganz klar
das muss anders sein wenn man eine
regierung bildet und das traue ich mir
auch zu ich habe immer großen respekt
vor denjenigen mit denen ich für handel
und deshalb glaube ich wird sich niemand
über diese frage gedanken machen müssen
danke für heute erledigen vielleicht
sollte man das noch mal sagen ist ja
abgewählt worden durch dieses
wahlergebnis anders kann man die
wählerinnen und wähler botschaft gar
nicht verstehen weil sie etwa ein
prozent weniger haben als sie sind sie
abgewählt worden und sie sind gewählt
worden weil sie viele viele
prozentpunkte verloren haben das ist
doch eine botschaft
da das zählen immer die krise des
langsamen die preise des vorherigen wahl
ab
mit verlag glaube ich ist aber doch so
dass die bürgerinnen und bürger mit
verlaub eine botschaft ausgesandt haben
die jeder versteht und ich bin sicher
das wollen die bürger dass man das
beachtet das hat gerhard schröder vor 16
jahren auch geglaubt dass der verlauf
der kurve vor der wahl die wahl
entscheidet am ende war es dann anders
wir haben spannende wochen vor uns danke
für das gespräch
schönen dank
alexander dobrindt ist der chef der
csu-landesgruppe in berlin und damit der
mächtigste bayer in der stadt wenn
markus söder nicht zu hause ist guten
abend nach berlin was gehört herr kleber
die befürchtete niederlage ist nun
ausgeblieben ganz knapp was machen sie
da raus
wir haben den trend gebrochen der
letzten wochen der die spd immer weiter
steigen hat sehen und die union fallen
und deswegen ja daraus ergibt sich dass
eine konstellation möglich ist die mit
unserer beteiligung zu ergebnissen
kommen kann wenn die parteien cdu/csu
fdp und grünen jetzt in sondierungen
diesen weg einschlagen wollen wir haben
eine bereitschaft dazu und deswegen ja
es gibt eine möglichkeit dass wir ein
innovations- bündnis schaffen mit
wirtschaftlichen wachstum mit
klimaschutz und sicherheit als
hauptthemen und deswegen das kann sehr
spannend werden gestern fehlte ihnen
noch die fantasie dafür von einem
eventuellen zweiten platz aus eine
koalition zu schmieden was hat ihre
fantasie beflügelt
erstmal sie mir immer davon ausgegangen
dass wir wenn wir auf einem platz zwei
sind es rot-rot-grün eine möglichkeit
auf eine regierungsoption hat dieses
linksbündnisse gibt es jetzt nicht und
deswegen sind andere konstellationen
möglich und ich glaube es ist zwingend
notwendig dass man diese konstellationen
die es gibt dann auch sondiert oder
versucht zu einem ergebnis zu bringen
wie gesagt unsere bereitschaft an der
stelle ist da und deswegen bieten wir
diese gespräche auch an nun schaut man
noch ganz gespannt auf die stellen
hinter dem komma auch am ende hauchdünn
die spd vor der union liegt oder
andersrum ist das überhaupt noch wichtig
naja also natürlich ist es immer
entscheidend wer abschluss vorne ist da
kann es heute leider die sich manch
anderen gemacht werden aber wir werden
vielleicht morgen dann auch sehen wie es
ausgeht aber
entscheidend ist dass unterschiedliche
konstellationen möglich sind und
deswegen stehen jetzt die inhalte
stärker im vordergrund und genau nach
diesen inhalt muss man jetzt die
gespräche ausrichten
und dazu haben wir eine hohe
bereitschaft und deswegen ja das muss
jetzt in sondierungen hineingehen nun
ist ein bisschen in den hintergrund
getreten das die union ein katastrophal
schlechtes das schlechteste ergebnis
ihrer geschichte erzählt hat erzielt hat
ist das jetzt schwamm drüber wir müssen
koalitionsverhandlungen führen oder wird
da irgendwann mal noch abgerechnet
ist kein ergebnis dass ein zufrieden
macht das ist richtig aber ist ein
ergebnis des 1 aber auch verantwortung
gibt und diese verantwortung der muss
man nachkommen an einem wahltag und muss
die bereitschaft daneben auch haben
koalitions oder sondierungs gespräche
aufzunehmen
fehleranalyse kann man immer noch
betreiben aber zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt erst mal muss man diese
verantwortung die an der wähler jetzt
gegeben hat nachkommen wenn armin
laschet jetzt die gespräche führt muss
er ja wohl als chef der cdu und dann
erfolgreich abschließt und kanzler wird
dann können sie auch nicht mehr mit ihm
abrechnen
wir führen die gespräche gemeinsam das
ist richtig und wir haben das ziel eine
koalition zu schaffen in der armin
laschet kanzler wird ja und das ist ja
eines der obersten ziele die man
gemeinsam verfolgt regieren mit cdu und
csu an der spitze
trotzdem wird man natürlich auch dann
aus den fehlern lernen müssen und
deswegen kann man an einer aufarbeitung
ja nicht vorbeikommen aber die
konsequenzen sind natürlich ganz andere
wenn man es schafft in eine regierung zu
kommen danke für das gespräch und noch
einige nacht alles gute
und dieses gespräch mussten wir ein paar
minuten vor der sendung aufzeichnen
jetzt ist eine sehr eigenartige lage
entstanden nicht in der sendung in der
politischen landschaft die ehemals
großen parteien union und spd haben
getan was sie konnten die wähler haben
gewählt und alle fragen sind offen am
längsten hebel sitzen jetzt zwei
kleinere parteien die fdp und die grünen
der auf denen die beiden sich
verständigen wird kanzler und der andere
halt nicht britta spiekermann über zwei
ungleiche parteien die jetzt partner
werden sollen
jubel am ende gewinne für die grünen
doch weit ist die partei zurückgeblieben
hinter den eigenen ansprüchen
sogar die kanzlerin schafft schien
greifbar annalena baerbock machte fehler
und doch sie applaudiert sie strahlt an
diesem abend als sei vergessen dass sie
sich und ihre partei selbst formulieren
gestoßen hat dieses land braucht eine
klima regierung das ist das ergebnis
dieser bundestagswahl so metternich
werden das in den nächsten tagen
gemeinsam dieser verantwortung gerecht
werden und zwar so wie immer gemeinsam
schade wir wollten eigentlich das mikro
teil es ist so eine sache mit dem teilen
habe denn die zweite reihe
zurückgetreten war könnte jetzt den
ersten platz beanspruchen seine
unzufriedenheit mit dem wahlkampf
zuletzt kaum noch verdeckt habeck
vizekanzler die grünen sprechen von
ihrer nähe zur spd könnten diese nähe
aber auch bei der union finden das
bündnis müsse eine eigene idee
formulieren ist müsste zunächst zu einer
eigenen politischen stärke finden auf
sich selbst habe auch seinen anspruch
anmelden können wenn das gelingt es ist
interessant das gleiche kann aber
theoretisch auch unter der führung der
cdu passieren auch sie gehören zu den
umworbenen die liberalen die mitte
entscheiden werden über die künftige
bundesregierung die fdp hält sich alle
optionen offen jamaika 2017 schon einmal
an der fdp gescheitert in der berliner
runde betont lindner erneut große
schnittmengen mit grünen und der union
ich habe die parteiprogramme alle
gelesen und wenn man das tut stellt man
fest dass die größten inhaltlichen
übereinstimmungen zwischen den
unionsparteien und der fdp sind das habe
ich vor der wahl gesagt und das will ich
nach der wahl auch ausdrücklich
wiederholen großer frust bei den linken
die fünf prozent hürde wird mit glück
wahrscheinlich geschafft mehr nicht ein
linksbündnis unmöglich drastische worte
für den absturz
das ist wieder endlich geschaffen das
sagen die haben das profil ist ergebnis
und dass es so schlecht wird hätte ich
nicht für möglich gehalten und ich hoffe
natürlich dass wir trotzdem noch alle
unterkommen die auftrag geben sie
konnten zuletzt mit ihnen wollte und
will keiner eine koalition die afg hat
verloren mit maximalforderungen wie
masken runter raus aus der eu gegen
klimapolitik wahlziel verfehlt trotzdem
demonstrative zufriedenheit man hat uns
ja prognostiziert das dfg eine
eintagsfliege im bundestag ist dass man
uns nach der ersten legislatur auch
wieder aus dem bundestag hinaus wirft
das haben wir wieder legt wer wird mit
wem koalieren es werden schwierige
gespräche und wer wird am ende kanzler
an diesem abend gibt es viele offene
fragen über nacht werden sie nicht
beantwortet
aber sie müssen beantwortet werden vor
allem auch von den grünen guten abend
frau baerbock
mit der spiekermann sagte gerade im
bericht ist scheint schon vergessen zu
sein dass sie mal ganz nah an der
kanzlerschaft waren und es dann sagen
wir verspielt haben ist es vergessen
nein ist es natürlich nicht und deswegen
haben wir heute abend auch deutlich
gemacht dass wir uns nicht über alle
maße freuen können weil wir haben zum
ersten mal in der deutschen geschichte
eine kanzlerkandidatur ausgerufen und
gesagt wir wollen führende kraft in
diesem land werden das haben wir
offensichtlich nicht erreicht und das
schmerzt und zugleich haben wir unser
ergebnis deutlich verbessert und in
diesem wahlkampf einen aufbruch möglich
gemacht die union herausgefordert es ist
dann am ende halt so ein zweikampf
zwischen uns und der union gekommen
sondern zwischen der union und der spd
und hat in den letzten zügen noch dazu
geführt dass gerade wechselwähler
zwischen rot grün von uns grünen dann
auch noch zur spd ihr übergegangen sind
deswegen ist das am ende bitter aber der
auftrag ist klar und deutlich wir stehen
dafür dass die nächste bundesregierung
eine klima regierung wird und das ist
die aufgabe unserer zeit mit der wir
jetzt in voller verantwortung in diese
gespräche reingehen wäre ist nicht
angemessen nachdem doch viele in ihrer
partei und die allgemeinheit auch davon
ausgeht dass ihr partner robert habeck
ein besseres ergebnis erzielt hätte ihm
jetzt so etwas auch in ihrer
partnerschaft wie die erste geige zu
geben
es gibt ja keine erste und zweite geige
gespielt wie die ausbeute als
kanzlerkandidat genau und jetzt ist der
wahlkampf vorbei und wir haben auch mit
der kanzlerkandidatur deutlich gemacht
dass wir in die regierung gemeinsam als
team reingehen werden wir haben das ja
auch in den wahlkampf für eine
kanzlerkandidatin aufgestellt haben aber
immer wieder deutlich gemacht wir treten
hier als spitzenteam an und wir werden
als genau dieses team jetzt auch diese
sondierungsgespräche gemeinsam in voller
kraft in voller verantwortung führen
sie haben gerade von olaf scholz gehört
möglicherweise dass er sagt der verlauf
der kurven weise darauf hin dass
eigentlich die meisten bürger gerne die
spd in der spitze sehen fühlen sie sich
von diesem votum der wähler verpflichtet
jetzt er mit der spd zu reden als mit
der cdu
wir haben die finalen zahlen ja am ende
des abends noch nicht deswegen ist auch
noch nicht ganz klar wer am ende ganz
vorne liegt bei dieser wahl was für mich
deutlich geworden ist was für uns als
grüne klar ist wir brauchen jetzt einen
echten aufbruch das hat dieser wahlkampf
deutlich gemacht wie viele menschen sich
in diesem land eine erneuerung wünschen
die haben jetzt nicht alle grünen
gewählt deswegen werden wir diesen
aufbruch nicht anführen aber das ist
grundlage für uns für jegliche
verhandlungen die aufgabe unserer zeit
ist deutschland klimaneutral zu machen
für soziale gerechtigkeit in einem
industrieland zu sorgen was in zukunft
dann kein co2 mehr ausstößt und das ist
grundlage für alle gespräche in die wir
jetzt rein gehen werden und wird ja
gerade auch die berliner runde wo auch
deutlich gemacht wurde dass es nicht so
ist jetzt hat eine partei ganz ganz
tolle gewonnen und die anderen müssen
sich mal ein sortieren sondern natürlich
wird es auch gespräche mit den anderen
parteien von unserer seite aus geben
auch mit der fdp geben weil der aufbruch
kann nur gelingen wenn wir jetzt bei der
zukunft auf frage klimaschutz nicht nur
halbe sachen weitermachen würden jetzt
bitte ich sie das zu beantworten ohne
nochmal teile des wahlprogrammes
vorzutragen sie kennen die parteien sie
kennen die personen saßen gerade mit
ihnen zusammen würden sie völlig
gleichwertig
beurteilen die chance dass am ende mit
olaf scholz und kristler nimmt etwas
zustande kommt oder ob es mit laschet
und christian knapp
wir haben ja auch vor der wahl deutlich
gemacht dass wir gerade im bereich der
sozialen gerechtigkeit große
schnittmengen mit der spd haben deswegen
auch ein zweierbündnis zwischen spd und
grün was gewesen wäre was er dort eine
aufbruch hätte schaffen können es reicht
aber nicht für ein zweierbündnis und
deswegen muss jetzt gemeinsam gesprochen
werden wie wir die frage sozialer
gerechtigkeit und klimaschutz
voranbringen können und welcher
kombination das am besten funktioniert
weil gerade beim klimaschutz gibt es
zwischen union und spd ja jedenfalls in
den letzten monaten keine unterschiede
das ist aber die aufgabe an der wir als
grüne diese bundesregierung gemessen
werden weil es eine klima regierung sein
muss nicht weil die grünen stark
geworden sind sondern weil das der
auftrag des pariser klimaabkommens ist
dankeschön für heute abend frau berbalk
und eine interessante nacht wünschen
als christian lindner an jenem
unvergesslichen novemberabend 2017 die
jamaica gespräche beendete eine
koalition aus cdu grünen und fdp
unmöglich wurde da stand marco buschmann
hinter lindner damals frisch gebackener
erster geschäftsführer der fdp-fraktion
das ist er auch heute noch und ist ist
ja die fraktion die laschet oder scholz
die stimmen leihen muss guten abend herr
buschmann sie kennen ihre fraktion wie
schätzen sie die stimmung wird ein
also wir sind unseren wählerinnen und
wählern verpflichtet unserem programm
verpflichtet wir wollen dass deutschland
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert endlich
ankommt bei der digitalisierung auch
beim klimaschutz aber auch bei der
modernisierung der sozialen
sicherungssysteme und darüber wollen wir
sprechen denn wir wählen ja kein
bundeskanzler oder haben heute kein
bundeskanzler gewählt sondern den
deutschen bundestag und bundeskanzler
wird wer im bundestag eine mehrheit hat
und deshalb über die inhalte eine
mehrheit hinter sich versammeln kann ihr
vorsitzender lindner betont immer wie
eng er mit seinem freund lasse
zusammengearbeitet hat es ist überhaupt
denkbar dass eine gemeinsamkeit genügend
einsamkeit entsteht zwischen ihnen und
der spd unter olaf scholz und den grünen
ist das nicht ziemlich weit hergeholt
wenn man ihr wahlprogramm neben das
begrünen liegt
also jetzt müssen erst mal alle
verantwortungsbewussten demokraten
miteinander sprechen denn der wähler
auftrag ist in einer hinsicht klar die
ränder wurden geschwächt die mitte wurde
gestärkt die gruppe wurde abgewählt denn
beide große parteien haben in summe
verloren und deshalb ist jetzt der
australier der beiden risi regierung
bilden also können zu denen ich ständig
vorhalten dass sie beide jetzt nur so um
die 25 prozent haben
das tue ich ja auch gar nicht aber wir
leben ja in einem neuen parteien system
die sogenannten volksparteien haben
keine 30 oder auch keine 40 prozent mehr
sondern über 70 prozent der menschen
haben sich jeweils gegen die
volksparteien entschieden sondern
wünschen sich ein stärkeres gewicht der
concept parteien die grünen
beispielsweise über ökologische
nachhaltigkeit die fdp bei einer
umfassenderen nachhaltigkeits begriff
der klimaschutz aber eben auch
wirtschaftlichen wohlstand und die
modernisierung des staates mit
beinhaltet wir sind mit diesem programm
wahrscheinlich sogar stärkste partei
unter den erstwählern geworden das heißt
die menschen wollen eine regierung der
zukunft und in dieser regierung soll die
fdp eine wichtige rolle spielen und
diese verantwortung werden wir gerne
wahrnehmen und das geht aber nur dann
wenn wir uns auch inhaltlich in dieser
regierung wiederfinden vor vier jahren
gegen das nicht da waren die angebote
entsprechend schlecht jetzt glaube ich
kann das gelingen weil viele vernünftige
menschen um einen tisch herum auch in
der lage sein sollten eine vernünftige
lösung zu finden der tisch das ist noch
mal ein interessantes stichwort wie
läuft das dann jetzt praktisch gefragt
den geschäftsführer der fdp fraktion
muss das ja am ende entscheiden wer ruft
jetzt wen an und wo trifft man sich gibt
es da irgendeine art von plan oder
werden sie dann ab morgen drauflos
improvisieren
also die parteien werden sich jetzt
erstmal spreche ich machen die werden in
ihre gremien gehen die tagen morgen alle
und meine erwartungen wäre dass
spätestens am ende der woche alle
miteinander spreche ich sind die grünen
haben da ja einige voraussetzungen volle
regeln ihrer satzung aber in einer woche
muss man spricht fähig seien und ob man
da miteinander telefoniert sich sms oder
whatsapp schickt das überlassen wir mal
dem technischen fortschritt darauf kommt
es nicht an und dann finde ich es klug
ich finde es wirklich klug wenn auch die
parteien einzeln miteinander sprechen
auch fdp und grüne miteinander sprechen
denn das sind die parteien die jetzt die
veränderung in die regierung hinein
bringen müssen das sind die parteien die
insbesondere von den jungen menschen in
diesem land einen auftrag bekommen haben
das land in die zukunft zu führen und
deshalb wäre es auch klug wenn diese
beiden parteien sich nicht im weg stehen
würden sondern dem land tempo und beine
machen würden damit wir im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert ankommt
bei der digitalisierung bei der
demografie und auch bei der wirtschaft
der zukunft das klingt nach vernetzten
wochen danke schön herr buschmann und
eine angenehme nacht
kleber
so und wir kommen noch mal wie
versprochen zurück zu den analysen denn
die wahlergebnisse sind das eine die
motive und tendenzen dahinter das
eigentlich noch spannende matthias da
gibt es einige ja versuchen wir
gemeinsam zu verstehen was da heute
abend passiert ist und dazu schauen wir
auf kandidaten auf themen und oft
kompetenzen und fangen an mit der frage
für das abschneiden der union war armin
laschet als kanzlerkandidat hilfreich
das sagen nur elf prozent er hat sogar
geschadet sagt eine mehrheit von 56
prozent und das ist ein
niederschmetternder wert für olaf scholz
sieht es genau andersrum aus noch
deutlicher 70 prozent sagen dieser
kanzlerkandidat hat der spd genutzt
jetzt gehen wir von den kandidaten zu
den themen und gucken auf die
kompetenzen da sehen wir bei den
wichtigen themen rente soziale
gerechtigkeit den roten balken der spd
deutlich vorn im klimaschutz
erwartungsgemäß den der grünen also der
kandidat der spd und die themen das
passte offensichtlich ganz gut zusammen
und dann haben wir an den wahllokalen
umfrage gemacht die forschungsgruppe
wahlen und gucken noch mal wären nach
altersgruppen die spd gewählt hatte noch
das ist sehr interessant da sehen wir
vor allen dingen hier oben dieser
waagerechte strich hier sind die 26
prozent die die spd insgesamt hat bei
den mittelalten 45 bis 59 hat sich schon
ein besseres ergebnis mit 27 prozent
gewinnt sechs punkte dazu und das hier
ist das interessanteste sie holt 35
prozent bei den über 60 jährigen und
dann deutlich überdurchschnittliches
ergebnis das ist eigentlich die domäne
der union immer gewesen da ist es der
spd mit dem kandidaten und den themen
gelungen einzubrechen
matthias interessante details da werden
die noch viele wunden lecken und zahlen
studieren müssen alle parteien
miteinander dankeschön nach berlin und
wir kommen noch mal zu theo koll theo
das waren ja heute viele andeutungen den
gesprächen und in den elefantenrunden
und so weiter sichtlich weichen auch die
freundin auf bei allen beteiligten die
märkte einen teil der macht kriegen wir
nur mit kompromiss wie wird das jetzt
heute nacht und danach weitergehen was
glauben sie ich glaube es wird eine sehr
dichte woche morgen tage ja schon die
parteigremien und am dienstag dann die
fraktionen das sind insbesondere bei der
union wichtige seismographen ja auch für
die position und die macht von armin
laschet also wie viel kritik gibt es an
ihm und diesem historisch schlechten
ergebnis insbesondere die fraktion ist
da sehr wichtig denn dort gab es ja in
der entscheidungsphase eine mehrheit für
markus söder laschet selbst viel weiter
parteivorsitzender bleiben und von dort
aus die sondierungsgespräche führen es
dürfte glaube ich zusätzlich auch diese
woche schon direkte gespräche zwischen
grünen und liberalen geben also den
beiden kanzler macher parteien und dann
samstag ist dann schon ein kleiner
parteitag der grünen der könnte schon
erste zwischenergebnisse beurteilen
spannende wochen vor uns nicht nur eine
dankeschön theo und hier nun zu dieser
teilweise auch verwirrenden lage an dem
abend der wahl der kommentar vom
chefredakteur des zdf peter frey
am ende dieses wahlabends wissen wir mit
gewissheit nur dass die ära merkel zu
ende geht das wahlvolk hat deutschland
heute in ein patt geschickt und sich für
einen schwachen kanzler entschieden egal
ob er was wahrscheinlicher ist scholz
oder laschet heißen wird es gibt dafür
jetzt gleich zwei zünglein an der waage
spitz gesagt grüne und liberale können
jetzt miteinander ausmachen wer unter
ihnen kanzler wird apropos kanzler oder
kanzlerin annalena baerbock wird es
nicht ihr anspruch war zu kühl die
fehler zu viele trotzdem sind die grünen
jetzt mächtig wie nie weil er
solidarisch mit seiner co vorsitzenden
geblieben ist ist robert habeck gestärkt
und steht jetzt als nummer eins der
grünen für viele ämter bereit anders als
markus söder auch er ist für den absturz
der union mitverantwortlich
mit stänkereien und unfrieden fast bis
zuletzt der lacher im aartal isla scherz
wahlkampf entgleisen für seine stärken
interessierte sich niemand mehr seine
politische zukunft ist ungewiss für ihn
gilt jetzt entweder jamaika oder nichts
olaf scholz profitierte von den fehlern
der anderen ja und von einer ungewohnt
geschlossenen spd
kontrolliert bis zum schluss hat er
seine partei aus dem 15 prozent keller
geführt dass er so lange rot grün rot
nicht ausgeschlossen hat bot der union
angriffsfläche heute hat er nur noch
eine option die ampel aber anders als
laschet ist der mann mit dem größten
plus des abends ein gewinner und in
seiner partei stark wie nie stand jetzt
könnten noch beide kanzler werden aber
laschet droht einen aufstand von cdu/csu
als verlierer des abends müsste er einen
hohen preis zahlen um die grünen in
seiner jamaika koalition zu locken aber
auch scholz wird federn lassen müssen
zum beispiel in der steuer und
finanzpolitik um die fdp für seine ampel
zu gewinnen zwei kleine parteien sind
heute abend zusammen fast so stark wie
die spd
oder cdu csu grüne und liberale werden
anders als die geschrumpften
volksparteien auf jeden fall gebraucht
nach merkel wird die republik unter
die einschätzung des chefs des
chefredakteurs des zdf peter frey und
nun zu den nachrichten außerhalb zu
wichtigen ereignissen im ausland als
eines der letzten länder in westeuropa
erlaubt nun auch die schweiz die ehe für
alle in einer volksabstimmung votierten
gut 64 prozent der schweizer für eine
öffnung der ehe für
gleichgeschlechtliche paare aus
verwaltungstechnischen und rechtlichen
gründen kann es allerdings noch dauern
bis lesben und schwule heiraten können
mit dem votum von heute dürfen sie
künftig auch gemeinsam kinder adoptieren
im besetzten westjordanland sind bei
einsätzen der israelischen armee
mindestens fünf palästinenser getötet
worden nach israelischen angaben seines
kämpfer der radikalislamischen hamas
gewesen die terroranschläge geplant
haben sollen um diese zu verhindern habe
die armee mehrere razzien durchgeführt
allein in burg in wurden dabei zwei
hamas-mitglieder erschossen die
radikalislamische hamas kontrolliert
seit 2007 den von israel abgeriegelten
gazastreifen und ist auch im
westjordanland aktiv wegen der massiven
versorgungsengpässe seitdem rexit
lockert großbritannien die strengen visa
regeln kurzfristig will die regierung
tausende fachkräfte ins land holen 5000
lkw-fahrer und 5500 arbeiter für die
geflügel verarbeitung sollen bis
heiligabend befristete arbeitslose
bekommen aktuell fehlt es vor allem an
lebensmitteln sowie an diesel und benzin
vor den tankstellen im ganzen land lange
warteschlangen
auf la palma ist er vor einer woche
ausgebrochenen vulkan weiterhin aktiv
nach eintägiger schließung wegen der
niedergehenden vulkanasche ist der
flughafen der kanaren insel wieder
geöffnet
wegen der anhaltend schlechten
flugbedingungen aber wurden auch heute
viele flüge gestrichen
die zahl der durch die lava zerstörten
gebäude ist auf über 460 gestiegen ein
ende des vulkanausbruchs können experten
nicht vorhersagen
berlin berichterstattung hat heute abend
eine zweite eine landespolitische ebene
an einem wahltag auch voller berliner
pannen ist dann doch ein ergebnis
zusammengekommen berlinerinnen und
berliner haben auch heute für heute auch
ihr abgeordnetenhaus neu gewählt und
hier sind die ergebnisse
die spd kam auf 21,9 prozent die cdu auf
17,4 die grünen auf 19,9 linke 13,9 afd
8,2 die fbp 7,4 und die anderen es gibt
eine menge davon in berlin schaffen es
in summe auf 11,3 prozent markus große
berichtet
für einen moment fühlen sich die grünen
schon wie der wahlsieger
euphorie nach der ersten prognose doch
die lage ist verzwickt einmal liegen sie
von einmal die
spd-spitzenkandidatin bettina jarasch
hat aber das bislang beste grüne
wahlergebnis in berlin eingefahren es
sind prognosen die zeigen dass
unglaublich viele berlinerinnen und
berlinern uns ihr vertrauen geschenkt
haben dass wir eine aufholjagd
ohnegleichen hingelegt haben und das
wäre nur niemals ohne euch möglich
gewesen liebe freundin und ich bin
völlig ich finde es völlig
bei der spd dagegen nur verhalten der
jubel nach den ersten zahlen im laufe
des abends deutet sich jedoch ein
leichter vorteil an entschieden ist aber
noch nichts bei der spitzenkandidatin
banges warten und ein vorsichtiger
optimismus
sich ganz klar wir haben jetzt ein sehr
enges rennen wir müssen das ergebnis des
abends abwarten unser ziel ist es
selbstverständlich stärkste kraft in
berlin zu werden und ich hoffe auch dass
es im laufe des abends noch gelingt
blumen für kai wegner ein dankeschön für
seinen einsatz im wahlkampf jedoch der
cdu-spitzenkandidat hatte sich mehr
erhofft er wollte rot-rot-grün ablösen
wahlziel verfehlt nun sogar das
historisch schlechteste wahlergebnis der
berliner cdu der bundestrend war nicht
unser freund so und das haben wir
gespürt und ich glaube dass wir schon
deutlich merken dass rot rot grün in
berlin sehr sehr unbeliebt ist dass der
und die unbeliebteste landesregierung in
ganz deutschland und es scheint
alternativen zu geben nach der wahl
jubel bei den linken spitzenkandidat
lederer insgesamt zufrieden leichte
verluste zwar aber vier stärkste kraft
geblieben im wahlkampf hat die linke als
einzige partei bedingungslos die
enteignungs initiative deutsche wohnen
unterstützt jetzt hofft sie auf eine
fortsetzung der bisherigen koalition
dass rot-rot-grün offenbar hier doch
sehr sehr deutlich zugelegt hat und das
alles mit dem bemühen darum sich davon
abzusetzen am ende nicht so richtig
verfangen hat und dass wir ja hier
zumindest anja bei dem boden sind wo wir
beim letzten mal aufwand das ist nach
den viereinhalb jahren rackerei ja auch
keine selbstverständlichkeit
versteinerte mienen bei der afg das
ergebnis der letzten wahl nahezu
halbiert eine herbe schlappe für die
spitzenkandidatin christine brinker auf
die jetzt schwere zeiten zukommen bei
der fdp die stimmung gut die liberalen
haben leicht zugelegt sind aber nicht
zweistellig wie angepeilt
spitzenkandidat sebastian czaja hofft
dennoch auf eine regierungsbeteiligung
in einer möglichen dreier koalition
auch das ein thema an diesem tag in
berlin chaos vor den wahllokalen lange
warteschlangen fehlende unterlagen und
genervte berliner
organisation ist leider nicht so gut zum
blödesten flughafen zu bauen da kriegt
auch keine wahl so sieht es heute mal
aus dem marathon mit ball an einem tag
ist einfach mal des öls so geht ein
verrückter tag zu ende um 22 uhr liegt
die spd vorn doch es bleibt spannend im
abgeordnetenhaus
die zweite landtagswahl im schatten des
bundes passierte heute in mecklenburg
vorpommern 26 mal so groß wie berlin
aber nicht mal halb so viele einwohner
und genau eine dominierende politische
figur die ministerpräsidentin manuela
schwesig spd sie stand den bürgern heute
zum ersten mal zur wahl sie war ja quasi
spd-intern ins amt gekommen als ihr
vorgänger erwin sellering schwer
erkrankte sie hat heute gewonnen
eindrucksvoll kann man sagen das
ergebnis die spd ihre partei kam auf
38,8 prozent die afg auf 18,1 die cdu
auf 13,9 die linke auf 9,5
und die grünen auf 5,6 prozent fdp 5,7
aus mecklenburg vorpommern berichtet
anja kinos
sonst zeigt sie fassten emotionen am
wahlabend in schwerin sind sie ihr
anzusehen manuela schwesig hat zum
ersten mal gezeigt sie kann eine wahl
gewinnen ein klarer sieg getragen vom
amtsbonus in der korona krise und dem
bundestrend und ihrer omnipräsenz im
wahlkampf sieg an ministerpräsidentin
bleiben ich bin sehr berührt denn hinter
unserem land liegen schwere zeiten durch
die korona pandemie auch hinter mir ganz
persönlich und dass wir heute diese
stärke bürgervotum bekommen für die spd
in mecklenburg-vorpommern für mich als
ministerpräsidentin das ist großartig
ein ergebnis so gut wie seit fast 20
jahren nicht mehr für die nordost spd
das ergebnis der cdu historisch schlecht
wieder landet sie hinter der afg wieder
nur platz drei wie bei der letzten wahl
spitzenkandidat michael sack gelang es
nicht sich in einem jahr als landeschef
bekannt zu machen seit die union als
juniorpartner mitregiert verliert sie
stimmen und ich will es mal so deutlich
sagen für die cdu in mecklenburg
vorpommern haben wir heute abend ein
katastrophales ergebnis erhalten denn
eines ist klar die wählerinnen und
wähler haben uns an dieser stelle nicht
mehr so deutlich vertraut die afg besser
als in letzten umfragen auf platz zwei
ihr protest gegen korona maßnahmen zu
kohl stimmen aber das ziel stärkste
kraft zu werden verfehlt und die partei
muss stimmen verluste im vergleich zur
letzten wahl hinnehmen spitzenkandidat
nikolaus kramer nennt gründe
wirkt sich natürlich auch auf unsere
landtagswahlen aus na klar die inneren
streitigkeiten die wir hatten die aber
mittlerweile
doch behoben sind die linkspartei zweite
grosse verliererin des abends auch hier
ein historisch schlechtes ergebnis
trotzdem hofft spitzenkandidatin simone
oldenburg mitregieren zu können in einer
rot-roten koalition es liegt ja auf der
hand dass spd und linke schnittmengen
haben viele schnittmengen haben dass der
spd in den letzten jahren das soziale
ein bisschen flöten gegangen
die fdp könnte es nach zehn jahren
zurück in den landtag schaffen der
bundestrend hat geholfen dasselbe gilt
für die grünen sie sind wohl ebenfalls
nach fünf jahren wieder mit dabei sechs
parteien wohl im nächsten parlament das
gab es noch nie in schwerin rot schwarz
hätte die stabilste mehrheit rot rot
oder eine ampel lehrer wohl auch drin
auch das muss sich entscheiden es gab
heute auch auf anderen feldern noch
sieger und verlierer in der fußball
bundesliga hat der sc freiburg klar
gegen augsburg gewonnen 13 0 freiburg
damit auf platz fünf der tabelle und das
andere sonntagsspiel zuvor ging
unentschieden aus der vfl bochum und
stuttgart trennten sich torlos
es war ein großer tag für
formel-1-weltmeister lewis hamilton der
sieg beim großen preis von russland ist
der einhundertste grand-prix-sieg des
mercedes piloten
zweiter wurde in sotchi max verstappen
im red bull in einem am schluss ziemlich
rutschigen rennen wenige runden vor
schluss setzt in sotchi der regen ein
und sorgt für bis dahin ungeahnte
spannung in diesem raum brief an
russland der bis zu diesem zeitpunkt
führende engländer länder norris mclaren
pokert bleibt auf trockenreifen und
rutscht von der strecke weltmeister
lewis hamilton hat kurz zuvor auf reifen
für leichten regen gewechselt und zieht
vorbei der wm-führende max verstappen im
red bull fährt ein perfektes rennen von
platz 20 auf 2 lewis hamilton gewinnt
zum fünften mal in sotschi und zum
hundertsten mal in seiner karriere
übernimmt die wm führung sebastian
vettel kommt auf rang zwölf ins ziel
und das wetter wird nun herbstlich die
neue woche beginnt wechselhaft und es
wird langsam frischer im norden
überwiegen die wolken im süden bleibt es
oft freundlich im osten und auch in
bayern kann es den ganzen tag schauer
und gewitter geben im nordwesten erst am
nachmittag bei 18 bis 24 grad am
dienstag und mittwoch regnet es vor
allem im osten am donnerstag bleibt es
meist trocken es wird kühler am
donnerstag nur 14 bis 18 grad wie geht
es weiter mit politik das ist der tag
dafür die runde bei maybrit illner
schaut nach vorne und sagt jetzt müssen
sieger und verlierer verantwortung
übernehmen die einen für ihre
versprechen die anderen für ihre fehler
bleiben sie also dran und wenn sie
wollen sehen wir uns nochmal um 23.30
guten abend bis spät
[Musik]